hello everyone today I'll be talking
about supersearch with open search and
python
my name is Liza showa I'm developed
advocate for Ivan we're managed where we
manage open sources databases for you
I'm also contributor in the python
Community I am the leader of pandery's
Munich chapter and I'm really involved
in the python events in general
uh how about the agenda for today so
today we're going to be talking about
what is open search in case you don't
know what's open search I was also
moving forward uh why should you
consider open search in your application
and we're gonna see in practice how can
we write such queries with a demo so
wish me luck because demos are not easy
in life
so what is open search
open search is a direct Fork of Alaska
search version 7.10
so you can see it here I think I believe
right now open search is already in the
version 2.3.0 uh it's been more than one
year old project uh and this have become
quite different projects right now
what is it open search
open search has the name has its open
it's open source and when I talk about
open source software I mean that you can
download you can see the source code and
you can change it and you can use uh has
you wish
another great thing that open search is
and also has it in the name it's search
it is a search engine this is one of the
uh great things about open search that
it's very good search unstructured data
like text or things like this and yeah
it's a powerful search engine
it also comes with an analytics Suite I
know this sounds like a fence word uh
but what actually means is that you can
send your adapter to open search and
there you can drive like uh dashboards
like take some visualization to
understand how your data is
so uh open search comes with open search
dashboards which you can do this kind of
things
and uh although open search is very
powerful has a search engine a lot of
companies they do use open search to do
log analytics why because we use open
search can handle a huge amount of data
in nearly real time so when you send it
to open search it's already there and
you can do log analytics with that so if
you want to see how your application is
performance over time you can use open
search for that it's a very good
database
also if you are familiar with rest API
or maybe you're working on writing has a
back-end developer and you're familiar
first API you can use a rest API with
open search so it is something good you
don't need any other programming
language but of course you can also use
with python go Java node.js so it has a
lot of other clients that you can use to
interact with open search cluster
so those are some of the cool features
of open search
but now that we've heard why you should
consider using open search in your
projects
when I think about open search I think
about the superpowers that open search
has and when I think about superpowers I
think about the superhero so I try to
think if open search would be a hero
what kind of hero would open search be
I would say that if a massage would be a
hero open search would be able to speak
many languages open search has support
for more than 30 languages so if you are
sending your data to open search you can
actually specify which language is that
and it will optimize for searching
so if open search would be a hero would
speak mood languages it would be a
polypoly polyglota
I also try to think if open search would
be a hero it would be able to read your
mind I think you already haven't seen
this in other search Engineers uh when
you are typing something the social
engine it kind of guess what you wanted
to say based on relevant results or what
what whatever data is in your database
so open search has Auto completion
support which means that if you type
something it will try to auto complete
for you so this is a very powerful tool
if open search would be a hero can open
such understand my broken English you
may have noticed in my English is not my
mother tongue so I make type something
with mistakes but who doesn't right so
if a person should be a hero open such
would be able to understand uh broken
English because open such has support
for further searching we will see this
today but first searching basically
means that maybe mistypes are word uh
and you still want to get the relevant
results
open search does have support for that
another cool thing about open circuit
that's very Dynamic uh compared to other
databases that does require a very
strict mapping in the predefined mapping
before you sending your data open search
does not require that you can of course
and I would recommend if you know your
data very well you can define a Mappy
but if you don't know you can just send
it to open search and open search will
try to figure out what kind of fields
are there
so this is I would say some of the
superpowers of open search of course
there are more what I try to minimize
here uh now we're gonna see how can we
write search queries with open search
for that I have it here a demo uh I will
put the link now but I will also share
with you at the end of this slides so
for this demo we're gonna be using
python we're going to be using a open
search cluster which is already running
and we're going to be using lots of that
for the data I'll be using recipes here
is almost lunch time so I'm quite hungry
but I hope you can still if you already
a large time of breakfast around the
world uh maybe you see some interesting
thing here interesting recipe that yeah
you can always contact me I'll be happy
to send you this data or you can find
the data here also in this demo
so who is ready for writing some search
squares I am let's go so here is how the
data looks like so we have it here
directions uh that's how YouTube how you
prepare these recipes you have different
types here like data
um categories here uh protein and it's
different things here and we're going to
be focused here on the title uh because
yeah I don't want to work with all those
types here so we're going to be looking
into those recipes and try to find in
the titles
the first square that I want to show you
is the magic square
and the magic square now I will share
this screen with the code so I will
switch here
so we have it here I'll try to make a
little bit bigger so you can see it so I
have it here the Europa store if I go LS
you can see how it is structured here
and I'll just go over a little bit how
in readme so you can see how it is so
you have it here
with me where I'm using open search of
python which type of python I'm using
and I already have this Setter up but
I'm using iPhone search with certainly
running and yeah you can easily use that
okay so tap the open search yourself or
you can use a managed service such as
Ivan or WS they are good choices here so
yeah in this files
I have it I'm using Piper uh to make a
clear application that I will be using
to interact with my cluster
um and I have it here
search dot Pi for example let me show
you
so I have it here
oops not this one but I have here some
files that will help me to interact with
my cluster and one of the things that
search.pi in that file which I will show
you
I have it here some commands that I'll
be sending to interact with my cluster
in order to use that I will be using
search.pi and uh I can always use the
help function here which will show you
what kind of queries I have it here that
I'll be using for today I'm going to be
using now match query so let's see how
can we use this so python search.pi
match and help
so the match the match Square as you can
see it here oops as you can see it here
it performs search by relevance for
certain field and queer and we're gonna
be giving this a field uh and a curve so
first is the field and the curve so
let's start with our first query so we
have five dozers.pi title
and I try to look for some recipe that
is a various optic and one I found it
very exotic is chocolate and garlic so
let's write Chocolat here
and garlic
uh I was curious to see if some recipe
would come up I think it would be
interesting choice some people would
never try this but I would definitely
try it so let's see what comes up here
oops
sorry I have a typo of course in a live
demo you can always have this diaper
so let's let's run it uh I'm missing
title so this is the title actually so I
don't need to use this one
oops chocolate and garlic uh
ah okay I know what's missing so I have
to Define which pair I'm using uh which
field I'm querying for and which thing
I'm gonna be searching and you can see
it here that way I look for chocolate
garlic those are the recipes that comes
up the first one is chocolate garlic the
second one and all the other Wellness
they only have garlic in the name so
let's see how how this actually work in
the presentation
so the much the match clear which you
actually will do it will look in I have
it here python client uh with a function
called search oops which I will be
looking in the index that I send it to
open search for the universities uh with
a python dictionary like in this body
and here it will specify which kind of
query I'm going to be using in this case
was the match player and which kind of
field I'm looking for for in that
information as I told you we're going to
be such in the title fields and we have
it here the query which is the words
that I'm looking there and which kind of
operator we have
we had chocolate uh garlic but by
default the match Square actually uses
the ore operator
so coming back to the code if I want to
specify here you can see like yeah there
is chocolate and garlic in the first one
but other Autobots they only have garlic
so how could we make this uh to be just
chocolate and garlic
so what we can do is to use the operator
and Define it to use and
and we have it here now chocolate and
garlic so this is one one thing that you
must pay attention when you're working
with the match square is that by default
that we use the or operator but of
course you can always Define the N
operator to currently two words that you
are looking there
and we have a chocolate garlic Mojo with
toasted common bread which looks a bit
like this
one thing we can do also here one thing
we can pay attention is that although I
have it here uh let's leave it the or
operator for now
and let's change the order of
garlic coming first and then chocolate
actually let's use the operator ends
because uh I don't want all the other
ones with garlic so it feeds such here
you can see that although the order of
the ore words were swapped or was
chained I still I am able to find and
Resort here so although you can see the
actually the right part is that
chocolate comes first and then garlic
but I swapped this with the magic square
and still I can get some results maybe
this is something you want in your
application maybe not
but coming to a use case like let's
suppose my name it's a composed name so
my name is Liza Mida in case you are
looking for me in a database such as
open search and you are using that one
like the magic where
in case you write Myra Liza you will
still be able to find a result but it
doesn't mean that is the result that you
want so there are situations that the
order of the query words does matter and
for those situations you would be using
a match clear you would be using the Met
phrase query
so the Metroid Square what actually does
it takes into consideration or we will
look into your data considering the
order of the words by default uh you
have to find exactly met in that order
so let's see how can we find uh how can
you use the Matrix
so coming back here
we have it here
first of the pi and we have match phrase
which I believe is like this
foreign
like this some Maple is like this let's
see
it's written like this so here we're
going to specify the field and which
Square we're gonna be looking
um
Let's uh let's write let's look in the
title for the word
cake
foreign
was like 220 000 recipes so it's like a
lot of recipes and now we are searching
for the uh the quick cake and coconut in
title when we search for this we can't
find we won't find anything and I was
wondering how can we not find anything
if there's like so many
data there right but it's as I say the
match phrase they did in the match
phrase you consider the order of the
words of course here is not correct
English uh but my mother tongue is not
the English it's actually Portuguese and
we swap the words that's how we would
read in Portuguese really if I would
translate so of course now if we correct
this we should put coconut and Cake we
need to expect that the metaphase would
understand this and would bring some
results and this is what happens right
we have now here coconut cake in this
exactly order first coconut and second
cake in different positions in the
sentence here
this is uh something interesting because
even though you went to the match phrase
like maybe something like this sometimes
you if your user still type something in
that the order is a bit wrong but
sometimes you want to give some
flexibility to that
and match first has something called the
slope parameter so the slope parameter
is the acceptable distance between two
words so we have it here K coconut and
we saw already that we couldn't find
anything how could we give a little bit
of flexibility in your query that
actually maybe still will bring some
result
so let's put a slow parameter of one
that's how it works yes so we can see it
now that uh now we have cake with
coconut showing up uh in those query
cake of coconut cake of coconut cake of
floating so the distance here we gave it
was what if we go even further and give
a distance of two for the same query
what we will see is that now we have the
water one that we're acquiring for
example coconut cake coconut cake so we
gave more
distance uh flexibility and we can find
some squares
I am a very visual person so for me just
telling you that yeah that's how the
slow parameter Works maybe it's not that
easy so to help uh understand how the
slope parameter works I have it here
a way to explain you so we have it here
what do we were uh doc what comes up in
your document and actually what would be
doing where something where for cake and
coconut and what come up was cake with
coconut when we gave a pair of ice low
parameter of one
so how does this flexibility works so we
have it here that the second one so in
your query it was in the second position
coconut and we can move to the third
position and having a slow parameter of
one that's why we come up in the first
square with cake with coconut in many of
the results
if we give even further like uh when
Walker was K coconut and actually what
the results was coconut cake when we
gave a sub parameter of two what
happened is that uh it went from the
position two to the position one so this
is one slope and from the position one
the cake went to the position two so we
swap and this counts has a slope of two
that's why we come up with results like
coconut cake in the end
so I hope with this visual it was easy
to understand
a piece of cake to understand maybe even
a coconut cake so I hope you understand
how the slope parameter works with the
match phrase
moving forward we have fastness
uh we will write inquires to the open
search you can specify levels of
fastness which means what is it fastness
so fuzzness returns documents that
contains terms similar to The Search
terms but is measured by The Leverage
time distance so how to say maybe you
type something wrong and it still would
come up
here for example The Leverage time
distance accounts for this
chained in characters from the word
words that you are searching in the word
that's been querred in this case for
example can be a different character
here can be uh even removing or adding a
new character discount with one and can
we also like swapping words that are a
digital sense like act and Cat and this
is how uh we would see but we can see it
in practice how the firstness work so I
will go back to the code
and we're gonna write here python search
dot Pi uh match
the match query it does have a parameter
for falsness that we're gonna be using
so we have to give the type the
field.fini query
and uh what we acquire
one thing I try to find is like what is
it confusing in the English language and
in the word
with food and stuff in English one thing
that's confusing is the word desert and
dessert
if English is not a mother tongue maybe
it's confusing for you too one is sweet
and the water one is salt so in case you
mistype that uh because it's confusing
can you still get some results so let's
type it like desert here
we don't get anything losing the match
if we give some fastness level
everything
hope I type this correct for this level
like first is of one uh then we can get
some results right because the
difference between desert and dessert
it's one character that it was at the S
character so that's why you account for
fastness of what uh in the same way you
can see it here how is it in the code we
would have the python client and we're
going to be using the search
method and we always have to specify
which index you are looking for and you
have it here the match in this case
title
and we're going to be using the query
has the match and we're going to specify
the fastness level which comes up that
this these are the recipes like mango
and melon dessert the dessert room for
and a lot of delicious dessert here so
this is how the fuzzness uh kind of how
can you account for the fastness when
you're acquiring from your data like in
text field data
there is something cool you actually can
make this automatic so what happens is
sometimes if you're using fuzzness and
you are using a higher level of fastness
you can go from one word to another word
that is not actually relevant anymore
right
so to account with that open search
gives you the possibility to use
automatization like automatically we
look how your data is look the how long
the words are and will Define for you
which kind of fastness level would be
using so if we redo the same what we did
here but now using Auto
you will see that we would also be able
to find results here right
so this is how the auto use and I I
would recommend to always have set up as
Auto especially if you don't know all
the words in your data
and the firstness as I show you you
would just specify here has Optum and it
will show off some delicious recipe like
this
it's almost Christmas so let's see if we
can maybe find some Christmas recipe uh
some delicious one so if I do python
search that pie
I can just reuse this and
last food Christmas here
and see if we can find anything so we
can find actually Christmas Continental
Christmas tonic so interesting recipes
for your Christmas time if you celebrate
Christmas but yeah this would be some
stuff that open search has another thing
your message has is open search
dashboards which allows you to visualize
your data you would see something like
this and you don't need to know any
programming language to do the of course
python makes beautiful uh data
visualization uh but of course here if
you want to share this with everyone in
your company and people want to just do
the visualization they can use open
search dashboards for that and it's
really good so you see it here that I
use the count one I use the ratings to
see how this recipes were rated over
time and also uh I use this Cloud will
just show up which kind of recipes shows
up more more like peanut free probably
very important because if you have some
allergy to nuts you don't want to have
that effect
so thank you this is actually not all I
have to show you
I want also to show you a project that
we have that uses open search in
products so for example here if I look
for open search I have it here this is
the developer portal developer
documentation for my company and if we
look for open search here
and such you will see that it will show
up a lot of verses here and what we are
using in the back end is open search so
how does this work we actually have it
here it's open source so you can go
there and see how we use this in case
you are looking for a search how to
implement search engine uh using open
search we have it here I script in
Python which will look for all the
documents here
all those pages and it will send us page
to open search
and when we acquire I'm gonna be
querying from the open search
cluster so you can find it here in
practice how does it work uh and here is
the repository that I use for today's
talk uh you can also go there and
contribute I have other stuffs related
to open search like sending your data to
open search also different queries uh
and yeah it's also open source
um and yeah my company does manage Open
Source service so we have iPhone search
in case you want to check it out uh you
can start a free trial there you don't
need to add anything yeah you would you
could just try out of Insurgency if you
like thank you very much